the latest on Kim Kardashian after she  was robbed at gunpoint in Paris sunday  on Monday just hours after the scary  incident Kim's friends rushed to be by  her side longtime friend Jonathan Cheban  and Lala Anthony were both spotted  arriving to kim and kanye's new york  apartment to console her a source close  to Kim tells ET the mother of two is  still very very shaken up quote she  thought she was going to die they put a  gun to her head while they were  searching the apartment she was crying  begging them for her life the source  adds it's one of the most terrifying  experiences of her life when asked how  the robbers got up to the apartment our  source tells us quote the concierge  walked them up into the apartment with a  gun to his head et can't confirm Kim is  at home now with Kanye north and st. and  will stay in New York a week  you